i am going to show you now
the epitome of what was it in orwell's
84 it's it's like newspeak or
doublethink or
everything is reversed everything is
opposite night is day up is down etc
it is undeniable
that the alleged shooter's alleged
manifesto from buffalo
supports these ideas perpetuated
almost exclusively i mean just to be to
be conservative 99.8
by right-wingers uh there's no denying
that that's the rhetoric that was in the
manifesto so ben shapiro's approach
because listen everything's coming off
the walls for these people tucker was
saying that there was nothing political
about the manifesto at all ben shapiro's
approach is okay just claim that it's
left-wing stuff claim that the great
replacement theory that we have to worry
about non-whites changing the makeup of
the country and changing who we are and
destroy
ben shapiro just goes this is a
left-wing ideology he says that great
replacement theory contains an
essentialism about race
that to him looks like left-wing
woke-ism
it's it's
it's the trump thing of
don't believe what you're seeing don't
believe what you're reading just listen
to me instead check this out now the
left is trying to do is broaden out the
term great replacement theory to include
any sort of
normal concerns about illegal
immigration
any suggestions that demographic voting
patterns make a difference which of
course
everybody both left and right knows that
they do i mean the left has been
claiming for literally as long as i've
been alive changing demographic patterns
in the united states we're going to
shift the politics of the country in a
progressive direction is the base of roy
teshera's the emerging democratic
majority in 2003 so now what he's doing
there is kind of slick
uh we've talked about for a really long
time
that
over a period of decades demographics
shift in a natural way
one of the things that we've observed in
that shift is that certain states in
particular southern states
are becoming
slightly more what we sometimes call
latino or hispanic and slightly less
white and we've all said that will have
an effect on elections
that is not even remotely equivalent to
what the right does which is say
we have brown people
hyper breeding they're just pumping out
children
and it's a democratic strategy to bring
illegal aliens to the country so that
then eventually they will be naturalized
and as this conspiracy that's what the
right has been saying that's the right
on the left and really it's not the left
it's just in reality we go oh yeah
demographics shift over time and here's
how they're shifting
there
there's no conspiracy
to start
you know breeding hispanic women i mean
it's dystopian what they talk about and
ben shapiro wants you to believe that
it's kind of the same thing like you
know great replacement theory liberals
recognize demographic changes it's all
the same no it's not if you want to talk
about the great replacement theory and
what this person actually thought you
have to actually read the manifesto you
actually have to know what the great
replacement theory is yeah replacement
theory is the theory that essentially
there is a there are a bunch of jewish
elites and this coterie of jewish elites
which to perverts wishes to pervert the
racial stock of a country like the
united states a predominantly white
country in order to weaken the country
from within that is the great
replacement theory it is not concerns
about illegal immigration it is not
concerns about cultural assimilation
there are great republicans of course
that's very dishonest because the
mechanism that those who are purveyors
of the great replacement theory say
democrats are using is the bringing in
of legal and illegal immigrants i mean
it's he wants to separate the two things
crazy anti-semitic idea about jews
trying to change the demographics has
nothing to do with the immigration piece
actually no the the immigration piece is
the tool they claim is being used to
affect the change it you can't
disaggregate the two theory is the idea
there can never be cultural assimilation
the great replacement theory is the idea
that racism that race is destiny in fact
the racial essentialism of great
replacement theory looks a lot more like
wokism than it does like mainstream
conservatism or mainstream liberalism
there it is guys the great replacement
theory despite everybody espousing it
being a right winger is actually
left-wing it's now some people fall for
this now just as a reminder
it's all right-wingers promoting this
stuff here's tucker carlson saying that
immigration makes the country dirtier
and poorer these are right wingers okay
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight here's a funny thing
that we noticed the other day people
debate all the time about mass
immigration
what you never hear anybody do is make
the economic case for mass immigration
but as an economic matter this is insane
it's indefensible so nobody even tries
to defend it
instead our leaders demand that you shut
up and accept this we have a moral
obligation to admit the world's poor
they tell us even if it makes our own
country poorer and dirtier and more
divided dirtier poorer and more divided
and then more tucker i mean the stuff is
straight from right wing media
i'm laughing because this is one of
about 10 stories that i know you've
covered
where the government shows preference to
people who have shown absolute contempt
for our customs our laws our system
itself and they're being treated better
than american citizens now i know
that the left and all the little
gatekeepers on twitter become
literally hysterical if you use the term
replacement if you suggest the
democratic party is trying to replace
the current
electorate the voters now casting
ballots with new people more obedient
voters from the third world now as you
can see it's not just some vague thing
it's
this is the strategy of the democrats
that's the claim that's being made just
a couple more i know i played these
yesterday but they really should be
attached here so you can see how absurd
what ben shapiro is saying is here's
charlie kirk another right winger
president joe biden's department of
defense will accept 30 000 afghan
refugees in the military installations
following the collapse of kabul
boom
political
transformation
let the country crumble do you know
there's five million displaced people in
afghanistan now
this was all intentional
joe biden let it fall apart to now say
oh i'm so sorry i guarantee you joe
biden's speech this afternoon we'll talk
about refugee assistance and relocation
support so there it is this is something
the right says democrats are doing it is
not wokism and lastly lauren beaubert
same thing yes there is um definitely a
replacement theory that's going on right
now we are killing american jobs and
bringing in illegal aliens from all over
the world world to replace them if
americans will not comply with the
tyrannical orders that are coming down
from the white house so the ideal thing
would be
to say that there's nothing in the
manifesto
that is about great replacement theory
obviously they can't do that here so the
new move is oh that's all left wing
great replacement theory is actually a
form of wokism they are just lying to
you and many of their followers are
falling for it make sure you're on my
mailing list you can sign up at
davidpakman.com that will notify you on
monday memorial day about our
one day membership special i would love
for you to join on that day just get on
my mailing list at davidpakman.com we'll
take a quick break and be right back
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far
vincero sunglasses and jewelry and other
accessories are awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
fifteen percent off all products and
free shipping go to
vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below